I gotta say I obviously am obsessed with
people's hair and I have certain hair
heroes Jack Lord from the original
Hawaii five-o my hair Elvis I got honey
Jack Laura's story there Oh funny it's
weird okay you're at the right show we
don't really do funny anymore we do
weird yeah we you see with him on Hawaii
five-o yeah and it's not about the hair
he got the original when I was a kid
there was this original Hawaii five-o
and Jack Lord had like the coolest hair
and it was like a wave look um when I
was a kid I was like chuckle my hair's
gonna look like only orange you would
see that what we're doing is but he was
kind of he did some strange things as an
actor once in a while and he was behind
this desk and he was Garrett wasn't his
name he was yes theater he'd McGarity
McGarrett was and I was I was a bad guy
yeah and so he was grilling me so now
when we're doing his close-up
on my lines this is what he did we were
talking ID he say his line then I'd
start to say my line to him and he would
duck down and he had a death drawer open
he ducked anyone like this once we came
back up and did his line didn't begin
and tween line between lines I said Wow
yeah I love him even more now I just
start doing that during interviews watch
the gate story yes
just keep coming back well you know what
also I'm always I'm always like nursing
and then your hair in guardians of the
galaxy - we have a picture of this
fantastic hair it doesn't it doesn't
move the whole time what are they it's
like well I just want to sort of have a
you know he's eager living planets yeah
I wanted him to sort of have hair that
always looked like it was windblown and
stuff but I understand you do your hair
I do my hair and since I get out of the
shower and I put a little stuff in there
and do that and hit it with a hair dryer
and ready for the day that's it I I do
more I do a little more than that it's
it's six hours I go to a bar welders are
in there putting stuff do not crazy no
one I got in public people like can I
put my hands in there and for some
reason I was like sure why not
the cooky I say a character captain Ron
one time and he had long dreadlocks yeah
yeah it was the only time my life ever
ever girls literally would come up
Michael can I can I just touch your hair
yeah and slice um sure yeah and then
you're like you've got a great figure
help the extensions in there
you